for seams in the cortex each one longer
than the last played by seven happy
campers all of them having a blast
it's applause it's a blast it's all mine
hey youtubers it's Charlie oh my god
what's happening there's so much flash
news musical episode they announced the
black flash is Savitt are on the flash
season 3 so there's gonna be a breakdown
of all that stuff there's so much stuff
to talk about so let's just start with
black flash Savitt are they confirmed
that it's avatar most of you remember
him from the wally west run he appeared
during geoff johns flash rebirth the
original flash rebirth i know there's a
flash rebirth that's happening right now
that's totally different I'll talk about
that too later in this video but if you
have no idea who saboteur is he's
actually a pretty big character it's
just that he was really big during mark
Wade's flash run so that was a long time
ago so you can see in keeping with
tradition on the TV show they've taken a
big character from the comics like a
name changed his costume and they'll
probably change his backstory a little
bit just because this TV show version
looks more contemporary and just to
explain savatage backstory from the
comics a little bit he actually started
out as more of a max mercury Johnny
quick villain that got stuck in the
Speed Force you know way back in the
past and then brought into present-day
so you know eventually he becomes a big
Wally West villain but he originally
starts out as the villain of some of the
older versions of the flash so I always
loved it when the TV show does deep cuts
from the comics meaning you know because
max mercury and Johnny quake are so big
to sabotage story in the comics we might
see them pop up during season 3 but for
the most part he's a wally west villain
so it makes sense that they're doing kid
flash wally west on the TV show they
would also do a wally west villain from
the comics but the big difference in
savat are like in his grand plan the the
evil things that he's trying to do is
that his connection to the Speed Force
is a little bit different he wants to
steal it for himself but when he tries
to steal Wally Speed he finds that he
can't because Wally is bonded to the
Speed Force in such a fundamental way
like Barry Allen's bonded to the Speed
Force so that gets a little complicated
I'm expecting the TV show to change you
know some of that nonsense and make it a
little bit simpler but effectively
sabotage big plan is just to steal all
of the speed which they kind of did last
season with zoom so if there's gonna be
anything that they do that's totally
original to the show that like has no
basis in what they did in the comics
it's probably gonna be what's avatars
grand plan is because what happens in
the comics is that after he comes up
short against Wally West he had so
pissed that he's like
fine if I can't have your speed I'm just
gonna destroy the world which is like
the most overdone villain plot I'm gonna
blow up the world like they just did
that last season with zoom zoom tried to
blow up the multiverse so I don't think
they're gonna do the same thing two
seasons in a row you can see that
sabotage costume on the TV show just
looks a little bit like his comic book
costume with the earpieces flaring out
from his sides but the comic book
version of the costume is so ridiculous
looking then of course there's no way
they're gonna do it on the TV show but I
did wonder when we first saw this
costume it looked very mark waid wally
west era flash you know just like the
way they did the artwork on those
flashes so I did wonder if it was
something from that time period so now
it's confirmed
savat are deep cut from the comics the
other big news is that dr. alchemy will
be one of the big bads of the season and
of course i think that tom Felton is
playing the second version of dr.
alchemy he's like the younger version
that worked with Barry at the crime lab
in the comics but the really interesting
thing is is that I am DB lists Tobin
Bell from the saw series you know with
this really scary voice as playing dr.
alchemy so they might be doing the zoom
thing where dr. alchemy wears a mask and
his voice sounds really scary but when
he takes the mask off it's tom felton or
they might do legacy of evil type thing
where it's like his father like they do
it with the weather wizard where like a
version of weather wizard comes on but
he has a brother who later picks up the
mantle so just remains to be seen how
dr. alchemy appears and whether his
character changes or if Tom Felton's
character picks up the mantle from his
father or if he's gonna be the character
the entire time but if you don't know
who dr. alchemy is from the comics he's
someone who doesn't start out evil but
he's someone who butts heads with Barry
at the crime lab and then later becomes
one of the flash rogues but his powers
are like a combination of magic and
science so they were teasing that there
would be plenty of Harry Potter
references and easter eggs is they're
gonna have a lot of fun with it but oh
my gosh there's so much other stuff
that's happening I'm gonna need to do
like ten videos to explain all this
stuff but they're bringing on killer
Frost's mother like Caitlin snows mother
is coming on the show she's supposed to
be this super even killer frost
from earth to the evil version of
Caitlin said that her mother on earth
too was also a like they had that
in common like Caitlin's very sweet
killer frost is like the evil version of
her both of their mothers super
so it's going to
a lot of fun to meet her mother on the
TV show but no idea how many episodes
she's gonna be in they talked of course
they talked more about the four night
crossover so what's gonna happen is is
that it will touch on Supergirl
but the thing that really sets it off
we'll start on the flash so my guess is
is that Supergirl is gonna stay on a
different earth they're gonna do
something on the flash that will bring
her to earth one for the rest of the
crossover so when she gets onto the
flash then the story will cross over to
arrow the next night then legends of
tomorrow the last night but they did
confirm that that's going to be episode
eight of all those shows so that'll drop
sometime in November around the same
time that it dropped last year but
there's another big crossover they
announced they're actually doing a
musical episode
Supergirl flash crossover that will
probably feature characters from air on
legends of tomorrow but it really just
be flash and Supergirl so that is gonna
happen
episode 13 which will be in the back
half of the season but that'll be like a
smaller thing but it'll still be like a
big event but it just won't be quite as
big as the four night crossover so I
almost forgot next big thing there's
only gonna be 22 episodes of all the
shows this season instead of 23 which
isn't that big a deal like it's not
something that you should freak out
about and there's only 13 episodes of
legends of tomorrow instead of 16
episodes but as expected flashpoint is
only gonna last for a couple episodes
then it'll go back to normal with a lot
of the changes sticking like Wally West
will still be kid flash even after they
fix flashpoint stuff like that so
there's a whole bunch of stuff that's
going on with Supergirl season two like
they confirm Miss Martian they confirm
Montell Superboy like I'll do a separate
video for Supergirl season two in a
separate video for legends of tomorrow
Justice Society stuff tomorrow so be
sure to subscribe to get all that stuff
there's a new round of the DC giveaway
going on right now all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video the really big
thing tonight is that the Star Wars
rogue one Darth Vader trait like the big
trailer is dropping it's supposed to be
a different version of the celebration
trailer like different footage so
that'll be the next video that I post
tonight so get hype it's gonna be
awesome there's so much awesome stuff
that happened today while you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for
my flash season 3 trailer video and you
can click here to learn all about
Superman
Supergirl season 2 stuff thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys too